good morning believe nation today's
message is you have to have fun over to
you Steve Wozniak don't necessarily
think that you have to have the home run
in the huge apple computer on your first
start I spent a long time in my life
with skills just building little devices
for fun for fun is one of the key things
does that drives you to think and think
and think and make it better and better
and better than you ever would if you're
doing it for a company build things at
first for yourself that you would want
if you're going to build a retail or a
real estate business online well if
you're not in the real estate business
you're not going to really think about
it the right way you're building it for
other people that's what I say is wrong
you should be building it for yourself
and if you're not building it for
yourself you better have a tight
partnership with somebody that is that
absolutely wants it for themselves
because they're going to want it to be
so perfect and so right and not
confusing and make it all the beauty
into the product this is an important
message front runner is because a lot of
business people in the first starting
out to just chasing an opportunity you
think you can make a lot of money in
something so that's why you start your
business and that's typically the worst
reason to wanna start a company you want
to do something you love something
you're passionate about something that
is fun for you you want to find
something that you wish you could get
paid to do it and then go do it finding
a way to make money off of something
that's fun for you and that you love is
the fastest path to build a successful
company if you try to make money just
chasing opportunities you're most likely
going to fail so my question the day for
you today is what's fun for you in your
business why did you start and why is it
fun for you leave a comment below I'm
going to join the discussion and look
forward to hearing what you have to say
thank you so much for watching have a
great day continue to believe and i'll
see you tomorrow again for another shot
events feso